Gordon Ramsay would [ __ ] kill me well
he doesn't know what's good so so I'm on
my way to McDonald's to pick up the
supplies for an Ice Cream Sandwich hack
that was blowing up on the internet
where you take two cookies and a
McFlurry and you make a delicious
ice-cream sandwich I'm gonna go get the
supplies and bring it back to my
co-workers to see if it lives up to the
hype have you heard of this viral tweet
about creating an ice cream sandwich
using McFlurry and to McDonald's cookies
that sounds like something I would have
done when I was 7 years old I've never
had either I've never had a McFlurry or
with Donnell cookie never had worry no
cookies an ice cream of course that's
delicious you own ice cream you want ice
cream I have not heard about that but it
sounds delicious a little nervous ice
cream I'm ready perfect for the
summertime is this the quarry oh yeah
hmm there's no wrong way though how has
no one done this before you simple boy
this is already a mess it's not as easy
to put the McCleary on the cookies I
thought it would be I already know this
is gonna be good I mean like an ice
cream it like the cookies I'm kind of
pumped beautiful Oh
[Music]
and it's dripping everywhere I may just
clean up a little
what hmm burger it's not half bad
oh my god this is delicious sure
I mean tastes like McDonald's no when I
ladyness sure [ __ ] delicious
obviously good it's messy I should have
put more McFlurry oh good
this is a lot of effort and look how
much ice cream that's coming out I'm
surprised it just like people are just
finding out about this now I like to use
my calories all the things are a little
tastier and or and or busier if you
could toss it in the freezer for like
two minutes I'm gonna give it away I
think does anyone want this sloppy happy
nice great sandwich I don't think we
have any takers it'd be awesome if they
Lucille was warmer do you think it
deserves to have gone viral I think it
deserves to be on the McDonald's menu if
you put fries in it cuz you know like
you people dip fries and ice cream and
then why not different McDonald's actors
take a cookie dip it into the McFlurry
saves you the mess you're welcome I do
this all day I yeah I don't care if I'm
black it was awesome
driving quick treat I'm coming for you